fun isn't something one considers and
balancing the universe
[Applause]
but this does put a smile on my face
[Music]
you guys the way daños talks about his
quest and that trailer makes it sound
like the Avengers are running from a
good time like he's just trying to show
them some fun balancing the universe
this is gonna put a smile on my face so
a lot of you requested a video on the
Infinity stones specifically because
there are a couple key moments during
the trailer that let us know how many he
has in which order he collects them in
and it also gives us some clues about
the fate of vision so if you are finding
me for the first time just be sure to
subscribe to get everything there's
gonna be all kinds of stuff happening
from now to the end of the year between
this and Star Wars so there'll be some
more imax giveaway stuff at the end of
the video so starting with the actual
finish gauntlet itself this is what it
looks like when he collects all the gems
it's an actual prop from the movies and
this is actually done to scale so this
is Josh Brolin normal human in real life
he's actually a pretty big dude holding
up the gauntlet in an actual size when
Thanos is wearing it so this gives you
an idea for how big a nose is compared
to the other Avengers because here's
Robert Downey jr. facing off against him
at d23 so in terms of actual size
they're not that much different so you
just have to imagine that Thanos is
almost twice as tall is Tony Stark but
going from left to right and then down
to Center it's orange for the soul gem
red is the reality gem blue is the space
gem purple is the power gem green is the
time gem and then in the center is
yellow for the mind gem so the greatest
number of gems we see him with during
the trailers when they're on that crazy
asteroid and he's pounding the crap out
of Iron Man he has at least three gems
and that looks like it's later in the
movie because earlier in the trailer you
actually see that moment where he puts
the space gem next to the power gem so
here he has two gems or at least you
can't see a third gem if he does have it
so the only reason why I say that he
probably has the time gem in this frame
here is because you see the light
bouncing off of it and there's a blue
shaft in a green shaft so it's like the
light is bouncing off the gems and
they're just winking at you giving you
clues about what's going on the clever
thing they tried to do to be more subtle
about it is is that when he puts the
fists up and frame here really close
he's got the thumb bent backwards behind
his
fists so you can't tell whether or not
he has the time Jim but this frame here
with the shaft of green light just lets
you know yeah he definitely has it that
means that as of this moment right here
he doesn't have the soul gem he doesn't
have the reality gem and he doesn't have
the mind gem meaning that vision
probably survives this early assault
from the Black Order
so when you see vision down on the
ground here screaming and pain and
Corvus glaive staff is stuck in his
forehead trying to extract the gem this
low-key confirms that Scarlet Witch cap
Black Widow and Falcon are able to fight
off Corvus glaive in Proxima midnight
invision survives so he still has the
mind gem we don't really know what's
going to happen to him once they take it
from him because Dana's will have to
collect all six gems at some point but
there is some really cool
behind-the-scenes clues about how that
might happen without killing vision that
I'll talk about in a second because it
involves some of the toys sets so it's
still open to speculation but the thing
is is you probably noticed that there's
some footage missing from the trailer
video that I did earlier this week there
was a bunch of footage that leaked out
and it were just a couple scenes from
this fight with vision in the black
order and then separately with the
guardians of the galaxy in the guardians
of the galaxy scenes it was actually the
guardians going to the collector's
fortress finding out that the anos was
already there and tried to beat the
location of the reality gem out of the
collector in that scene he says that he
doesn't know where it is he said he sold
it to someone else so we'll talk about
that in a second but the important thing
is is that we see Loki with the
tesseract which is the space gem we see
him putting the blue space gem in the
gauntlet that implies that the purple
gem which was already there is the first
one that he goes after which is the Nova
Corps so it sounds like he goes to
Xandar destroys them and who knows what
they've been doing with it whether it's
been in lockup this whole time or
whether they've been experimenting with
it because everybody wants to see Nova
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
that requires a major power upgrade but
based on the thor ragnarok post-credit
scene so just you know careful for
spoilers from that if you haven't seen
Thor Ragnarok yet we have to talk about
the end of the movie so the sanctuary to
ship shows up confirmed by Kevin Feige
it's called sanctuary 2 and we know that
that stano's because sanctuary is the
name of his home base it's implied that
he's come to Asgard because he knows
that the space gem is there
but also Loki is there he gave him the
mind gem in the scepter so maybe Thanos
is going to pound him a little bit too
he's gonna have to pound him anyway to
get the space gem out of his hands
whatever ends up happening we see him
put it in the gauntlet and then it
sounds like we get the Black Order going
after the different groups of Avengers
so Corvus glaive and Proxima midnight
going after vision in the mind gem then
we have evany Maw going after the time
gem it actually this scene now is
confirmed to be evany mah walking around
all these dead bodies so that implies
that he's made it into one of the
sanctums and because we see this shaft
of green light it looks like whatever is
happening with the other members of the
Black Order he's one of the few
successful ones he eventually puts it in
the gauntlet and then so that sort of
implies that when he's walking through
this portal here it's actually him using
the space gem to port onto this asteroid
so whatever ends up happening earlier it
sounds like they're successful in saving
vision and then you have this giant
attack of the outrider army maybe that's
where black dwarf goes and they're going
after Wakanda for any number of reasons
so there's a couple things in Wakanda
that are really important a lot of
people are just focusing on the soul gem
and yes that is a total possibility
we've talked about that in other videos
but there's also vibranium in Wakanda
but there's also some behind-the-scenes
stuff recently that implies that they
might go to Wakanda for help with the
other infinity gems because of the
technology that Wakanda has they're just
so much greater than anything that even
Tony Stark has it was a description of
one of the toys that they're gonna be
selling for the movie that involves
Sheree helping take the mind gem out of
vision without killing him so it's
implied that vision will be able to
survive into Avengers for once Thanos
collects all six of the gems but it
sounds like they need to go to Wakanda
for a number of reasons and that's where
one of the big final battles is going to
be if not the last battle of the movie
because it does seem like things
escalate and we don't see all the
Avengers here so this battle with the
three gems Iron Man spider-man in the
Guardians is happening simultaneously
while this attack on what Conda is
happening but the reason why I say
Spider Man on this asteroid even though
you only see Iron Man getting pounded
here is you see him crushing spider-man
into the ground on
rocks that look similar to the rock
formations behind him so it seems like
this is where they all meet up in outer
space but not everybody is there so I do
think that everybody will make it into
outer space in the final Avengers film
but it seems like this first film which
is mostly Thanos quest comic book
storyline
it'll be split you'll have people that
go into space you'll have people that
stay on earth but of the characters that
stay on earth it looks like they're all
in Wakanda here so I'm assuming it's
going to be Falcon Hulk war machine
Winter Soldier
Black Widow Captain America in all the
black panther characters including
Sheree who's not standing here the other
cool thing about this too is that you
may notice Captain America is wearing
Black Panther style gauntlets so when he
says get this man a shield he's probably
going to have the energy shield from the
comics and it'll be like the same
technology that Black Panther has in his
energy costume that sure he gives him
during that black panther trailer so
because there has to be some oh [ __ ]
moment the Avengers have lost before
they rally during Avengers 4 so what
might end up happening is as they go to
Wakanda to try and help protect vision
you have this massive invasion in black
dwarf or the other black order that
might show up are successful in taking
the mind gem and then later like at the
very end of the movie he puts it into
the gauntlet and unless they're being
very deceptive with where this asteroid
fight ends up happening during the movie
it sounds like he doesn't get the soul
gem or the reality gem either till the
beginning of Avengers 4 or at some sort
of post-credits moment letting you know
where those gems are so in this
Guardians scene where Thanos is looking
for gem the collector says I don't know
where it is I sold it to someone else
so based on everything we've seen so far
it sounds like he's actually telling the
truth and he doesn't have it because
otherwise Stannis would have it later in
the movie when he's pounding all the
Avengers here leave all your video
requests in the comments below
what'll happen is is I'll do some more
Avengers this weekend I also have some
DC stuff to get through and there's some
new Star Wars that I'll be posting later
today they talked about the end of Rey
in the Star Wars universe like the
actress is like I'm definitely done at a
certain particular date so I'll talk
about that but there's a new round of
that imax ticket giveaway all you have
to do to enter just be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video
congratulations to the winner from the
last video Alan Dean
please private message me so I can get
your contact details I'll just name the
new winner in the next Marvel video that
I post click here to rewatch the trailer
a billion more times and click here for
the brand-new midseason finale flash
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight